let's talk about another space that
people have some concern about which is
autonomous driving is sort of security
concerns that's another real world
system so do you have should people be
worried about adversarial machine
learning attacks in the context of
autonomous vehicles that use like Tesla
autopilot for example they uses vision
as a primary sensor for perceiving the
world and navigating in that world what
do you think from your stop sign work in
the physical world should people be
worried how hard is that attack so
actually there has already been like
there there have always been and like a
research shown that's for example
actually even with Tesla like if you put
a few stickers on the road it can
actually wide range in certain ways it
can fold that's right but I don't think
it's actually been I'm not I might not
be familiar but I don't think it's been
done on physical worlds physical roads
yet meaning I think I saw with the
projector in front of the Tesla so it's
a it's a physical suppose you're on the
other side of the side of the sensor but
you're not in still the physical world
the question is whether it's possible to
orchestrate attacks that work in the
actual physic end-to-end attacks like
not just a demonstration of the concept
but thinking is it possible on the
highway to control a Tesla that kind of
idea I think there are two separate
questions one is the feasibility of the
attack and I'm hundred percent confident
that's the is possible and there's a
separate question whether you know
someone will actually go you know deploy
that attack I I hope people do not do
that yeah two separate questions
so the question on the word feasibility
the clarified feasibility means it's
possible it doesn't say how hard it is
because in their to implement it so sort
of the the barrier like how how much of
a heist it has to be like how many
people have to be involved what is the
probability of success that kind of
stuff and couple with how many evil
people
are in the world that would attempt such
an attack right that but the to my
question is is it sort of I you know I
talk to you a mosque and a same question
he says it's not a problem it's very
difficult to do in the real world that
you know this won't be a problem he
dismissed it as a problem for
adversarial attacks on the Tesla of
course he happens to be involved with
the company so he has to say that but I
mean they mean lingering a little longer
do you see you where does your
confidence that it's feasible come from
and what's your intuition how people
should be worried and how we might be do
how people should defend against it how
Tesla how way Moe how other timeless
legal companies should defend against
sensory-based attacks on whether on
lidar or on vision or so on and also
even for light actually that has been
researched shown even like it's really
important to pause there's really nice
demonstrations that it's possible to do
but there's so many pieces that it's
kind of like it's in it's kind of in the
lab now it's in the physical world
meaning it's in the physical space the
attacks but it's very like you have to
control a lot of things to pull it off
it's like the difference between opening
a safe when you have it and you have
unlimited time and you can work on it
versus like breaking into like the
crowns stealing the crown jewels or
whatever right in terms of how real this
attacks can be and when we to look at is
that actually you don't even need any
sophisticated attacks already we have
seen in the many real world examples
incidents where showing that the the
vehicle was making the wrong decision
wrong decision without attacks right and
this is also like so far with many talks
about work in this ever serious setting
showing that today's learning system
they are so vulnerable to the
adversarial setting but at the same time
actually we also know that even in
natural settings these learning systems
they don't
generalize well and hence they can
really misbehave and there's certain
situations like what we have seen and
hence I think using that as an example
okay so you should can be really they
can be real but so there's two cases one
is something it's like perturbations can
make the system is behaved versus make
the system do one specific thing that
the attacker wants as you said targeted
that seems you know that seems to be
very difficult like a extra level of
difficult step in the in the real world
but from the perspective of the
passenger of the car here oh I don't
think it matters either way whether it's
yeah it's misbehavior or a targeted
attack okay
and also and that's why I was also
saying earlier like if one defense is
this multimodal defense and more of
these consistence checks and so on so in
the future I think also it's important
that for these autonomous vehicles the
right they have lots of different
sensors and they should be combining all
these sensory readings to arrive at the
decision and the interpretation of the
world and so on and the more of these
sensory inputs they use and the better
they combine the sensory inputs the
heart rate is going to be attacked and
hence I think that is a very important
direction for us to move towards so
multi modal multi sensor across multiple
cameras but also in the case of car
radar ultrasonic right sound even so all
of those rights right exactly
you